hello
i am thorsten whitman from the
department of cell and tissue biology
at the university of california in san
francisco
today i would like to tell you about our
recent work
on using optogenetics to locally and
acutely control microtubule dynamics in
life cells
to ask questions about how the
microtubule cytoskeleton
shapes cell morphology dynamics and
function
i also would like to place this in the
context of neuron development on
morphogenesis
as vividly illustrated by this image of
differentiating stem cells
neurons are some of the morphologically
most complex cells in our bodies
and microtubules play a critical role in
generating this complexity
for example this image shows the outline
of a very young cortical neuron
differentiating from a human-induced
pluripotent stem cell
as you can easily see microtubules shown
here in white
invade every single one of the nascent
growth cones branching from this neurite
many neurodevelopmental disorders are
caused by proteins
related to the microtubule cytoskeleton
and in fact
there is now even a name for such
diseases that are caused by mutations in
tubulin itself
microtubules are cylindrical hollow
polymers of alpha-beta tubulin dimers
that are arranged head to tail in
protofilaments
in most mammalian cells 13
protofilaments are arranged in a
staggered helix to make up the
microtubule wall
gtp-loaded tubulin dimers polymerize
onto the microtubule plus end
and gtp is subsequently hydrolyzed in
the microtubule
wall gtp hydrolysis is associated with a
conformational change
longitudinally along tubulin
protofilaments moving adjacent tubulin
dimers closer together
gtp and gdpi loaded tubulin subunits
are thought to protect the growing
microtubule plus end from sudden
depolymerization
the structure of this protective cap is
complicated
and still not completely understood but
recent cryoelectron tomography data
have challenged older ideas in the field
and now strongly suggest
that microtubules grow as individual
curved protofilaments
that subsequently close into a tube
cells control microtubule polymerization
dynamics
and microtubule network organization on
many levels
for example c-cap5 or x-map-215
is a microtubule polymerase that
facilitates the addition of gtp
tubulin dimers to growing protofilament
ends and by itself
c-cap5 accelerates polymerization of
pure tubulin
by 5 to 10-fold
other proteins specifically recognize
the microtubule wall conformation
associated with the tubulin guanosine
nucleotide state
and binding proteins or ebs are thought
to bind to the gdpi tubulin conformation
near the growing microtubule end while
the neuronal microtubule associated
protein double cortine
recognizes the gdp microtubule lattice
this difference in specificity is shown
here in a cell expressing
m cherry tag eb-1 displaying the
characteristic comets at growing
microtubule ends in purple
and gfp-tagged double cortine in green
that binds along gdp microtubules and
does not overlap with eb-1 comets
double cortine of course is well known
for its function in brain development
as a multitude of double quartet
mutations can cause this encephalitis
spectrum diseases in which new neurons
do not properly migrate through the
developing cortex
however the molecular function of double
quartet in developing neurons is not
well understood
a few years ago we found that double
cortine specifically recognizes
straight gdp microtubules and our more
recent work in neurons indicates
that double corten is only present on
straight microtubules in growth cones
we hypothesize that double quarter
mediated mechanical stiffening of these
microtubules
may be important for growth cone advance
but this is a different story for
another day
instead i want to now focus on our
efforts to control protein complexes
at the end of growing microtubules that
depend on plastic protein interactions
with eb1
eb1 is a dimer with c-terminal carponin
homology domains
that recognize the growing microtubule
end structure
the n-terminal eb homology domain has a
hydrophobic pocket
that binds disordered protein regions
containing sxip
peptide motives that are also surrounded
by positive charges
there are about 40 such so-called plus
tips and mammalian cells
with diverse and often poorly
characterized functions
that are recruited to growing
microtubule ends through interactions
with eb1
because in cells microtubules grow on
the order of 20 micrometers per minute
we wanted to develop an optogenetic tool
to control plastic protein networks
at growing microtubule ends with high
spatial and temporal accuracy
while there are several plant and
microbial photoreceptors
that can be harnessed for optogenetic
approaches the love 2 domain of old
phototropin 1
that implants mediates blue light
phototropism has several advantages
the loft 2 domain is small only requires
a flavin mononucleotide cofactor
that is present in all eukaryotic cells
and reverts to the dark conformation
relatively quickly
upon absorption of a blue light photon
the major conformational change is an
undocking and unfolding of the j
alpha helix at the c terminus of the
loft domain
we further used an optogenetic system
pioneered by the han lab
in which a protein a z domain was
selected by phage display
to bind with high affinity to the loft 2
domain dark state
but this love2c dark complex rapidly
dissociates in blue light
this is seen in this proof of principle
experiment in which purified love 2 and
c dark
molecules only form a complex in the
dark but this complex is absent when we
run a native gel
while exposed to blue light
to generate a photoinactivated eb1
variant that we named pi eb1
and that could replace eb1's function as
a central plus tip complex organizer in
the dark
we inserted the love2c dark module
between the eb1n
and c-terminal domains with the
expectation
that blue light would result in
dissociation of the plus tip adapter
from the microtubule binding domain
resulting in disassembly of the plastic
complex at growing microtubule ends
this project was mostly worked by a
talented postdoc jeffrey
franharen who recently started his own
group at the erasmus medical center in
the netherlands
indeed in an experiment in which we
transiently expressed both halves of pi
eb1
tagged with different fluorescent
proteins blue light had no immediate
effect on the n-terminal domain
that directly binds to growing
microtubule ends in contrast the
c-terminal half
very quickly dissociated from growing
microtubule ends with a half-life of
less than 200 milliseconds
importantly the very rapid blue
light-induced pi ev1 dissociation
together with dark re-association
kinetics on the order of seconds
allows for subcellular control of plus
tip complex dissociation
with high spatial and temporal accuracy
this experiment of a cell expressing pi
ed1
with only the c terminal part tagged
with m cherry
illustrates this by alternating blue
light exposed regions
between the top and the bottom of the
cell
m cherry c dark eb1c rapidly
locally and reversibly dissociates from
growing microtubule ends
only in these blue light exposed regions
with this graph
showing the blue light illumination
profile and relative eb1c
plus and association when the top half
of the cell is exposed to blue light
and this graph showing on and off
switching of eb1 c
plus and binding in the two alternating
regions over time
on the other hand if we tag the n
terminal half of pi eb1 with m
cherry we can use this to analyze the
effect of pi eb1 dissociation on
microtubule polymerization dynamics
this movie shows 20 second time-lapse
sequences
of the same cell before during
and a few minutes after blue light
exposure demonstrating reversible
inhibition of microtubule growth
as indicated by a substantial decrease
of the microtubule growth rate
the duration of growth events and the
overall number of growing microtubules
lastly it is important to note that pi
eb1 is not dominant negative
and that in this and subsequent
experiments endogenous eb1 is removed
by either rna interference or crispr
genome editing and that in this case
all other plus tips that we have tested
also dissociate from microtubule ends
this brings up the question of how cells
achieve physiological microtubule growth
rates
in vitro purified tubulin polymerizes
much slower than microtubules growing
cells
and as i mentioned earlier while the
microtubule polymerase c-cap5 can
accelerate microtubule growth
by itself it is not sufficient to
support microtubule growth rates
typically seen in mammalian cells
however because there is published
evidence that there are interactions
between c-cap5
and the plastic protein network we next
tested fccap5 localization to growing
microtubule ends
dependent on eb1
however this experiment shows that in
contrast to ev1 dependent plus tips
which dissociate from growing
microtubule ends as a result of pi eb1
photodissociation
the dynamics of c-cap5 in cells appear
unchanged
this is further supported by our
observation that c-cap5 remains on
microtubule ends even in cells
in which both eb1 and eb3 have been
deleted by crispr genome editing
in addition microtubule associated c-cap
5 looks very different and much more
punctated
compared with typical eb1 comets and in
data not shown here
c-cap 5 localization correlates very
poorly with eb1 on growing microtubule
ends
these data and the current model that
microtubules grow as curved
protofilaments
prompted us to think that two different
structural transitions
on growing microtubule ends must occur
together
for optimal microtubule growth in cells
by itself
tubulin polymerizes slowly at rates of
one to two micrometers per minute
while c-cap5 catalyzed protofilament
elongation
can increase the microtubule growth rate
microtubules can only grow as
quickly as protofilaments close into a
tube and the formation of protofilament
lateral interactions
becomes rate limiting eb1 on the other
hand
binds between protofilaments and may
promote protofilament zippering but does
not increase the rate of tubulin dimer
addition
only if both structural changes are
optimally coordinated
microtubules grow at the high rates
exceeding 20 micrometers per minute
observed in mammalian cells
i have just shown you that pi b1
photodissociation inhibits microtubule
growth
but how does this affect the microtubule
network as a whole
in this pi b1 cell microtubules are
labeled with m cherry tubulin
blue light exposure is globally turned
on when the image on the left appears
that shows the gfp tag c terminal half
of pi b1
comets at the microtubule ends can be
briefly seen before pi b1 dissociates
soon after the blue light is turned on
microtubules begin to shorten and
disappear from the cell periphery
note that not all microtubules are
affected equally possibly indicating
microtubule populations with different
stabilities
while it is difficult to determine the
amount of polymerized microtubules in a
cell
it is quite easy to measure
unpolymerized tubulin fluorescence
and the increase of unpolymerized
tubulin in this graph
shows that the microtubule network
reaches a new equilibrium
within a minute
this is even more evident in a cell
expressing dominant active rac1
a small row gtpase that induces cell
edge actin polymerization and retrograde
flow
microtubules are rapidly cleared from
the right side of the cell
when it is exposed to blue light and
this induced microtubule network
polarity
can be maintained for an extended period
of time
although it is known that microtubules
polarize in most migrating cell types
such that the microtubule organizing
center and the bulk of microtubule
growth
are oriented toward the direction of
migration it is less well understood
if this microtubule network
reorientation is a cause or a
consequence of directed migration
we therefore used our pi eb1 cells to
address this question
the blue square in this video is not a
physical barrier
but simply an image of the reflected
blue light pattern
nevertheless this pi eb1 cell turns
around every time it enters a blue light
zone
and remains trapped within this virtual
box for more than 8 hours
this and other experiments indicate that
eb
dependent plus dip networks are required
for directional movement
and i invite you to read our paper for
more detail
the pi eb1 experiments that i have shown
up to this point
were all in a cancer cell line and
relied on knockout of the endogenous eb1
gene
and plasmid-based expression of pi ev1
constructs
to adapt this to more complicated cell
systems
such as developing neurons we came up
with a genome editing strategy
to insert a bicystronic genetic cassette
containing the love2c dark module
directly into the eb1 gene
and thus in one step convert eb1 into a
light sensitive variant
genomic pcr and immunoblotting simply
confirm successful insertion of this pi
element
and these images show induced
pluripotent stem cell colonies
generated in this manner in the dark and
during blue light exposure
demonstrating the expected pi eb1
dissociation at growing microtubule ends
the final experiment i want to show
today is work in progress
coming back to our initial question how
plastic protein complexes control
neuron morphogenesis this video
shows the extending neurite of a newborn
cortical neuron
differentiating from pi ed1 induced
pluripotent stem cells
the neurite growth cone advances along a
micro patterned laminine track
toward a blue light box
i will let you make your own conclusions
here but would also like to caution
that this is currently one of few
experiments and we are currently working
to combine such optogenetic assays with
chemotactic gradients
to test how growth cone guidance is
controlled by microtubule plus and
protein interactions
all that remains now is to thank our
funders the people who are doing the
work
and you for listening i'm happy to
receive feedback or answer questions
either by email
or on our twitter account thank you